poll question from over the weekend who
will be the 49ers week one starting
quarterback jimmy garoppolo
35
i think i'm squinting a little bit there
number three overall pick with 56
someone else percent so
and plenty voted nearly 20 000 voted and
that was the response whoever the number
three overall pick is will be the
starter our draft for today christopher
where will jimmy garoppolo play in 2021
uh who's got the trivia question do we
have one
no we got to go trivia we got to move we
got to move somebody talked too much
earlier in the show and it wasn't you
all right take the first pick all right
fine i'll take it uh all right well i'm
gonna go to the carolina panthers right
now if you're gonna make me pick one
team right now we're sitting here we
know they don't want teddy bridgewater
they can say whatever they want we know
the facts are out there
you know i i expect the 49ers yes to be
taking a quarterback at number three i
expected to be mac jones and jimmy g is
going to be available so i'm going to go
carolina panthers makes sense too i do
think he could run that joe brady
offense and really fit in nicely there
i saw a report over the weekend that
just felt like somebody was throwing a
dart to create some likes and retweets
on twitter that the patriots aren't
actively pursuing jimmy garoppolo
whatever that means no you're not
pursuing him at 25 million you're going
to buy your time you're going to wait to
make the move at the right time you know
you're going to get him for a good deal
if and when you get him they weren't
actively pursuing cam newton last march
either so i think the patriots to me
right now are the most likely
alternative at far less than 25 million
it'll be garoppolo and cam newton
competing
and
may the best man win and may the best
man face tom brady when the buccaneers
come to town during the 2021 season yeah
yeah i i hear you there that's it's my
mind you know mind went to that pretty
quickly when i first heard the news with
the 49ers i just thought oh man you know
will this make new england get back into
the jimmy g
you know
conversation
as far as yeah who cares we got cam
newton i don't know that i'm i'm going
to be interested to see what goes on
there certainly and we know that
belichick and china have a relationship
so i'm sure there'll be some open
communication if if new england does
want to do that um all right my next
pick
i'm gonna go to the denver broncos i am
i mean i'm trying to go
you know i just i look at that right now
and go okay i like drew lock i think you
and i both like drew luck we see some
talent where you go
wow like there's some throws and some
athletic ability that are they're
eye-popping i think there's some elite
traits to what he can do but we also
know there's a little bit of that i
don't want to say james there's a little
bit of that jameis winston factor too
where you go what why'd you throw that
or
why why why there was three guys there
don't try to fit that in the guy
underneath was wide open
um so we've heard denver you know in the
desean watson conversation
and you know
as of right now that's not looking great
i i just got to think that at the very
least with drew locke you can't just
roll out the red carpet forum this year
you can't just be like here
man we got nothing next behind you
that's that's even a threat at all we're
just gonna all go down in flames with
you if you go down in flames like i just
don't think vic fangio's gonna do that i
just would have a hard time so i think
at the very least they're gonna bring
some sort of competition in or something
like that and that's where i'll go with
jimmy jimmy garoppolo to the denver
broncos
i'm gonna go with the houston texans
yeah casario's there now as the general
manager he drafted well bill belichick
did but caserio was right-hand man when
garoppolo was drafted in 2014
and i know that they they have tyrod
taylor to a 10 12 million a year deal up
to something like that whatever the case
may be but if they're going to move to
sean watson or if he's not going to be
available because on the commissioner
exempt list or because he's sitting out
do you need somebody else i know they
traded for ryan finley but if garoppolo
is available at a good price the texans
make sense yeah i i hear that's
definitely what what popped in my mind
too that would have been my next pick
after this
uh it's there's a lot of new england
down there you know i still think
they're gonna run to new england type of
system on the offensive side of the ball
and i think there you know there's got
to be some people in that building aka
nick casario who like jimmy garoppolo
know what he can do so that makes sense
that that definitely does um this is now
where we get into the area of like
i don't know if there's any real
reality to maybe some of these next
teams okay
the next one i'm gonna go to is i'm
gonna pick the philadelphia eagles uh
i'll i'll throw them out there even
though i think that's really unlikely i
just look at it and go wait are they
just gonna again well kind of like we
just talked with denver you're just
going to go all in with jalen hurts and
just go
if he just if he fails we're just going
to let him fail we're going to go 2 and
14. are they going to have something
there to
wait kind of you know
salvage the the ship or whatever uh i
don't know there's not a lot of other
possibilities to me after what the teams
we've just picked so i'll go eagles as
my last pick here here's where i want to
be a real jerk and say tampa bay
buccaneers just for fun wouldn't that be
something
right wouldn't that be something right
um i i
you know yeah just becoming it you're
just you're or you you mean just well i
i really wanna i really wanna be who you
really wanna be a full-fledged jerk i'm
not gonna lie where i made a mistake we
could just i could have just said he
goes back to the 49ers that's what i'm
talking about 49ers yeah even look i for
all the reasons we discussed earlier and
all the points i've made on twitter over
the past few days
i believe that you don't make this move
yeah and keep jimmy garoppolo around
right but i can't rule out the
possibility they'll do something i don't
expect something that i would think is
not the smart thing to do and maybe they
hey they they're the ones who have the
jobs they put the super bowl team
together two years ago they may be
comfortable rolling the dice i would be
stunned if he's back at 25 million for
this year right i think if he stays it's
going to be for less money or they're
going to turn it into a higher incentive
package you can get 25 million if you
play all 16 games if you you know have x
number of yards if you do this if you do
that if we make the playoffs that's what
i would do take money away and give them
a chance to earn it back but uh the
49ers to me once we've exhausted all
these other options i i'd say that they
have to still be on the radar screen i
was thinking the bears maybe i know
they've already they've already gone all
in for dalton but but the bears would
make sense the dolphins could make sense
brian flores new england connection yeah
right i know that they they definitely
crossed my mind i even thought about
like i mean for for the sake of the
exercise you know
i don't know in some crazy world the
jets i mean i just i there's one of the
teams i wrote down but yes i don't know
if any any of them logically make sense
other than
really i think our first four picks
which were you know the patriots the
panthers the houston texans the broncos
i could see all those happening i'm with
you yeah the 49ers possibly but i don't
see that either you make a move to go to
number three
you know
quarterback you think okay they're gonna
make him the guy uh and and of course i
don't really see the eagles happening
either but but it'll be interesting and
something to watch here
one more to keep an eye on one more
if he gets cut
and if russell wilson gets traded
that would be intriguing i say the least
i don't think that's going to be me
in seattle i don't i'm not
right i mean i don't know i just get the
feeling from people in league circles
that's still
that's still a possibility that russell
wilson staying at seattle is still not
100 lock and we'll see once we get
through the draft weekend if that what
the reality is there
although he's been very positive on
social media about the moves the team
has been making so go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports